- [Gary] You can go
work at like 7-11.
Like, you just have to reset!
What the fuck are you gonna do?
("Monday to Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I been telling you.
("Basketball" by SkillyMusic)
(cheers)
- [DRock] Yeah!
- [Frederick] Gary!
- [Gary] Yes?
- [Frederick] Yo!
- [Gary] How are you?
- Listen.
It's crazy.
I saw you post
something on Twitter,
and you say that
you were gonna be here.
I'm like, maybe
I'll see this guy!
- You saw me!
- And I'm seeing you right now.
- That's awesome man,
what's your name?
- Frederick.
- Frederick, nice to meet you.
- Do you have a minute or two?
- I have to run to my Keynote.
- Yo.
Nice to meet you.
- Real pleasure.
- Awesome, man.
- I'm from Florida.
Thank you!
- Nice to meet you.
- [Frederick] Nice to meet you.
- [Tony] Tony Potts.
I hosted Access Hollywood
for a ton of years now,
I live in Playa Vista.
- Really nice to meet you.
- I've done videos for years
on what you've done,
it's been incredible.
- Thank you brother.
- Alright, you ready?
One, two, three.
Alright, and I'm
gonna come see you speak.
- Thank you so much, man,
really nice meeting you.
- [DRock] Pleasure, brother.
- [Anthony] Hey, can I
just get a picture with you?
- [Gary] Of course, man.
What's your name?
- Anthony.
Love your stuff.
- Anthony, nice to meet you.
- Where is my talk?
- Fourth floor.
- Fourth floor?
- E, F, G.
- Okay.
- We're going straight down to
Emily and
Cameron right down there,
they got the badges and
we're going right upstairs.
- [Man] I'm going
over to your talk.
- Thank you so much man.
- Yeah.
- Thanks for coming to it.
- No worries.
- How are you?
Yeah, we're in South-By,
we're in the eye of
the storm right now,
so it's gonna be pretty intense.
Gotta keep it chill.
You'll notice I'm
doing more looking down.
'Sup, man.
- Sup, brother?
- Dude, good to meet you.
- [Man] Super good.
You care if I get
a selfie with you?
- Sure, no worries.
- Perfect.
- Awesome man.
- Thanks for saying hello.
Hope you come to my talk!
- Okay, where's that?
- It's in 30 minutes upstairs.
- Oh, shit, we'll
get to the line then.
- [Man] I appreciate it.
- Yeah, take care, bye guys.
Good to see you.
- [Emily] Here are the badges.
Yeah, hi.
- In our hands, and then if
somebody gets transferred,
- Gary!
- Hi.
- Oh man, what's up?
- [Gary] Where you going?
- I've been
trying to give you socks.
- [Gary] Come back!
Gotta get some socks.
I need money actually.
- [Woman With Socks] Gary!
- [Gary] Oh, I'm sorry, I will
literally wear these tomorrow.
- I know, I've
been listening to you.
There you go.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- [Gary] Tyler, make sure
I wear these tomorrow.
(crowd murmur)
Hi, Mike.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, hi.
- Question,
- Go ahead.
- What is your advice
for startups who are growing
too fast and they
can't raise enough money?
- One more time,
they're growing too fast?
- But they can't
raise enough money.
- To slow down their burn.
- Right, slow down the burn?
- Sure, you only got two
options, you either can pay
your bills or you can't,
you either make enough money
to pay your bills, or
you raise enough money.
A lot of times startups grow,
but because of the markets
and the position it's in now,
they can't raise the capital,
so you gotta
turn down your burn.
If that's not the
problem and you're just sad
'cause you can't be
as big as you need to be,
you just need
to deploy patience.
Yeah, it's very basic right?
This world gets you
thinking differently,
but if you take a
step back, there's only two
or three things
your situation requires.
- [Woman] So do you mind
sending him a video message?
Jake.
- Jake, it's GaryVee.
We're here, but
you're not here, Jake.
- Where are you?
- And I don't know
where you are, Jake,
but we're very upset.
- You gotta get here.
- Get your ass here, Jake.
Jake, I hope I run
into you, see you man.
- Oh, thank you, oh my
gosh, thank you so much.
- You coming to my talk?
Everybody behind me.
(Emily laughs)
Good to see you.
- [Man 2] Long time.
- You well?
- [Man 2] Yeah, when
are you in L.A. next?
- 27th.
Good to see you, how are
you Sarah, how are things?
- So thrilled
that you're here again.
- Thank you.
- [Sarah] Do you guys want to
walk over to the room,
I'll take you back there?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- [Sarah] Perfect.
- I want to go to the front
of the room and
thank people for coming.
I'm not kidding actually.
- [DRock] What room is it?
- It's a couple of
rooms combined, I think.
- E, F, G, last year
Gary needed a bigger room,
than 18, but not
the biggest room.
- [Gary] You've got me so,
- [Woman 2] Hi!
- [Gary] Hi, that was such
a nice thing to say.
How'd it go?
- I don't know, how was it?
- [Gary] I'm sure it was great.
- Are you gonna come watch?
- Yeah I am,
I just want water.
- Hey how's it going, I'm Jay.
- Hello, I'm Gary, how are you?
Thank you.
- Hey, oh is this the vlog?
- [Gary] This is the vlog.
What have you got to say?
- I just wanted to
say, my fiancee Adam
is one of the biggest
GaryVee supporters,
he makes me learn
so much stuff from him.
And I'm not joking, the
first thing he said to me
about South-By was like,
you need to go meet with him
and you need to sit and talk
to him about social strategy
and all this stuff,
I was like, okay,
and then he texted me
your session and I was like,
that's the same ballroom as me
and that's right after my talk.
- [Gary] Serendipity.
- So I just want to
say, thanks for all the tips,
the advice, and I'm so excited
to see your talk, okay bye.
- Alright, let's do this.
Anybody have gum?
- [DRock] I do.
- Nice.
- You know you have a
reputation for just being
everywhere talking
to everyone at South-By.
- Like a good one?
- When I first started,
before last year,
they were like,
he's not gonna go
to the green room,
you're probably just
gonna see this guy talking
to all these people
in his session room,
and that's him, and
that's exactly what happened.
- That's what I like to do.
- [Emily] It's understandable,
so you know,
with the Gary factor...
I have this one from last year.
- What are you talking about?
- I'm doing a full Q&amp;A.
- Q&amp;A?
- Full Q&amp;A.
- Gonna be all inspirational?
- I tend to be inspirational.
- Should be like a Gary,
like DailyVee.
- You know what I'm doing, I'm
doing an Alexa voice skill,
in the morning while
you brush your teeth,
to get you,
- I love it.
- Mhmmm, isn't that cool?
The DailyVee.
- That's it.
- Daily inspiration.
- Daily.
Awesome, thank you.
Like this, right here?
- [Sarah] On the
stage left, yeah.
- Okay, cool.
Hi, nice shirt.
Hey guys.
Hey, thanks for being here.
What's up guys?
'Sup man?
Dude, good playing this morning.
Yes? How are you man?
- Good to see you.
- [Gary] Yes, dude.
What up man?
You're so handsome.
How are you?
- DRock,
I saw him at the
airport last night.
- You guys are cool like that?
Just gonna thank
people for coming in.
I'll be up in a minute.
You stay on the offensive
positivity if you believe it.
You manage the amount
of time you spend looking
and rubbernecking at negativity.
I don't give a fuck.
I see all the negativity,
I just know that
life is like this.
I expect things to be difficult.
I wanna remind everybody,
no matter where
you sit on politics
and things of that nature,
just data,
this is the
greatest era to be alive.
As sad as you are
about certain things,
I promise you
it'd be worse right now
if the Black Plague
was doing its thing.
(audience laughter)
So I think we get crippled.
I think a lot of people here
need to go and spend more
time with 80 and 90-year-olds.
And ask them what
they lived through.
Nothing's perfect.
We're always gonna have it bad.
It's always
going to be something.
We've always picked on each
other for being different.
It sucks.
So if you're lucky and
you don't have that in you,
I think you do
what I'm trying to do.
Which is be completely,
utterly on the
offense of positivity.
Because if you're
positive and you're happy
and you're optimistic.
You owe it to each
other right now to get louder.
Because the only
people that are loud
are the people
that are upset, right?
Negativity's on fire.
And happy people are clamming up
and staying away from it.
That's how we stay happy.
I went the other way,
I'm going right at it.
Putting it out every single day.
That's number one.
But we're all wired differently.
I'm able to eat shit at scale
for the rest of my life.
That's why I'm a leader.
That's why I'm a company.
It's why I put myself out there.
If you get fatigued,
you need to take
yourself out there.
It's okay to not
be there every day,
read every comment.
You don't bust
through on day one.
If you do not love the
process of what you're up to,
you've already lost.
It's true.
This shit's hard.
Like what do you want?
You want your
first fucking podcast
to be number one
on fucking iTunes?
Who the fuck are you?
(audience laughter)
That's the part.
You have to love it.
I love when people shit on me.
I love when I showed
up to the tech world
and like the wine guy thinks
he's gonna win this thing?
Yep.
I love going to
Madison Avenue and being like
this Twitter,
Business Week said Twitter boy
tries to start an agency.
I said fuck yes.
I'm about to do this TV show
on Apple: Planet of the Apps.
Recode writes Planet of the
Apps has four celebrity mentors:
Gwyneth Paltrow, will.i.am,
Jessica Alba, and others.
(audience laughter)
When I tell you that article
made me so fucking happy.
You gotta love the process, man.
I think people
have to listen to it.
You either have to be
massively entertaining
or really know what the
fuck you're talking about.
And when you have both...
(audience laughter)
You know what I mean?
There's plenty not
massively charismatic
over the top
assassins in what they do.
Because they
fucking know their craft.
They say it their way.
And by the way, maybe
they are better off in,
I'm obsessed with
getting everybody to understand
you have to find your medium.
Maybe you're a great writer.
Maybe you're
great in podcasting.
Maybe you're in video.
Maybe you cartoon
it up like Hugh Macleod
who dominates the scene the
of the early days of South-By.
You gotta find the
way you communicate
if you want to
communicate to the world.
Don't do podcasting
just 'cause it's trendy.
Got it?
Good luck man.
The loudest and best
relationships never win.
It's just what people
that aren't winning think.
It's the people that
are the best that win.
The market proves it for you.
So let's go in detail.
TechCrunch
doesn't pick the winners.
The Wall Street Journal
Three cool kids in the
crowd don't pick the winners.
The problem is everybody
wants to be anointed a winner
or best at what they do
before they've actually done it.
Let me just remind you
and everybody else here,
I built a business for
18 hours a day every day
running a wine liquor
store for 13 years every day
before I ever had the audacity
to come to
something like this and talk.
Let me tell you
something amazing.
If you're good enough,
you will win.
But if you are upset that
somebody else's grandpappy
got them ahead of you,
then you're gonna lose.
Everybody started ahead of me.
I'm just catching up.
- [Woman 3] How would
you then balance
being ambitious
and being patient?
- By recognizing
that you have no choice.
(audience laughter)
Do you understand?
I'm the most fucking ambitious
and most patient
person you've ever met,
which is why I'm gonna
win real, real, real big.
Find your version of that.
You have no choice.
Who's gonna cry for you?
What's the choice?
Are you ambitious?
- [Woman 3] Yes.
- Awesome.
I don't think you're as patient.
- [Woman 3] Yeah,
that's the problem.
- No shit.
(audience laughter)
And the problem right now
is that we're all
living public lives.
And all this horse shit,
this is what entrepreneurship
and success looks like.
Going to fucking Bali,
and fucking watches,
and private jets.
It's all horse shit, horse shit.
But it's fucking
with people's minds,
and they're getting impatient.
I don't give a fuck
what anybody else has.
I'm focused on my shit.
Start focusing on your shit.
You're a young woman.
How old are you?
- [Woman 3] 27.
- I'm gonna punch
you in the face.
(audience laughter)
You have your whole
life in front of you.
You know what I mean?
Put your head down
and do whatever this
thing that you wanna prove
that you're the best at.
If you actually
spend all your time
doing instead of dwelling,
you'd be much further along.
(audience applause)
Awesome.
I think with that I gotta go.
I love you guys!
I don't know,
listen we're all wired
differently, literally.
And I've lost plenty.
I just can't figure out why
I would spend any time on it.
- [Woman 4] Okay, but do you
keep trying with the same thing?
- [Gary] Yes.
There's been
many people who've won
on slight variations of the
same thing on the third time.
- Right, right.
- So just because
you believe in a thesis,
the way you
execute it within it.
Maybe you believe that
pies are gonna be huge,
but made a pumpkin pie
and it was supposed
to be a strawberry pie.
Got it?
- [Woman 4] Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] So it can still
be the same thing-ish.
Alright.
You have to make a change.
Sitting in your trapness
is not gonna do anything.
You have to basically get paid.
You can go work at like 7-11.
You have to reset!
- Yeah.
- [Gary] The fuck are
you gonna do?
You know what I mean?
What you're doing now
is clearly not gonna work.
I think what you're
doing is better for most people
than what I just did.
But for me selfishly,
I wanna answer
the person's question
that's right in
front of my face.
Just the health of my family.
Business doesn't scare me.
Business is what I do. You know?
I just don't understand.
The social
aspect of home schooling
is the thing I think is
fascinating, the pros and cons.
The education's non-debatable.
Like the kids are being forced,
literally, I would have
been aggressively medicated
if my teachers had their way
if I grew up in today's game.
- I suck shit at school.
I'm not stupid by any means.
- [Gary] I'm the worst
all-time student.
I don't think I'm stupid.
- So here's the thing.
- [Gary] You're not
interested probably.
- I feel like I could
be doing better things.
- That's what I got.
My bet is that my mom
would have thought it off
'cause we're old
school eastern European
and it's weird for
us to even take Tylenol.
But I literally watch
kids that are little me's
being completely
stripped of their magic.
Binary conversation.
- Can I get some
video real quick?
- You sure can.
Amy and Shridar,
this is gonna be a
very interesting video.
What got you successful
isn't necessarily
gonna get him successful.
Everybody's got
a different path.
Call his bluff.
If he's such a big shot,
and he's so awesome,
give him a year
to prove it to you.
And if he doesn't,
drag his ass to university.
What do you have to lose?
("Taker Her Down"
by Ruben Young)